I don't like like I don't know class
reunion class reunion
exactly it feels I mean we're so
overwhelmed emotionally
we're so numb we're exhausted and
tonight we get to celebrate with all the
people that we love and that's the most
important thing how's your head today
after shooting the finale and going
through you know it's it's been a
whirlwind we also had to shoot a show
and make it good and focus and also have
the emotions of saying goodbye and this
you know we were we were at set late
last night we woke up early to put our
hands in the Chinese Grauman theater
this morning and then my whole family's
you're from India I have like 12 people
staying with me it was such an emotional
moment for me personally and to see the
sacrifice that everyone made for me to
be here today what is that like getting
to submit yourself in Hollywood history
in front of your entire family yeah that
was the that was the real icing on the
cake was for them to be there because I
wouldn't have been there if it wasn't
for all the things that they did they
did without making me feel like they
were doing it for me because I wish all
of our hands could have been in this in
the cement but you know that's not the
way it was or the way it works but it
really is this industry and this job can
can be a lonely thing and I'm very lucky
to have a family that never lets me feel
like I'm a normal you know in reality
competition shows at the end of them
they always have like a prize for fan
favorite and in all my friends that I
talked about the show Raj is the fan
favorite
so we want Raj to still live on Raj has
stories to tell look the beauty of the
show is that you know we as viewers are
saying goodbye to the show but in the
world of the show the show goes on and
that's really a beautiful way to say
goodbye that's not what I'm asking Kunal
I'm asking if Raj can have a spin-off if
we can still tell his all my bosses are
here tonight so maybe bring it up for
them well we really happy with how he
ends up in the finale and were you happy
with where Raj ends yeah I think so I
think that I think wherever he is in his
life I think is is fine
it's it's it's just so beautifully done
by the writers and it's so simply done
and it's just I can't wait for you guys
to watch it because because I think
it'll really pull at your heartstrings
you know it's very beautifully done
[Music]
[Applause]